let's divide 518 by so let's going to
divide it by 0.7 0.7 so we're dividing
this whole number by a decimal so we
could also write this as 518 518 divided
let me write a little bit bigger than
that since we have to do some work with
it 518 divided by 2 the division sign in
white divided by 0.7 0.7 so the first
thing we do since we have this decimal
you were dividing by decimals to try to
turn this into a whole number somehow
well the best way to turn this into a
whole number is to multiply this by 10
which is essentially multiplying
shifting the decimal point over to the
right so this would become a 7 but we
can't just do that only for what we're
dividing by we also have to do that to
the 518 so that a value does not change
so we need to multiply both of these
times 10 so if we move the decimal over
to the right with the 0.72 turn into a 7
we also need to move the decimal over
the right for 518 now you're probably
saying I don't see a decimal in 518 well
there is one you just didn't have to
write it because it's 518 point to the 0
zero and we can add as many zeros as we
want so we if we move the decimal to the
right it becomes 5,180
so really what we're saying is 518
divided by 0.7 is the same thing is the
same thing as five thousand five
thousand one hundred and eighty five
thousand one hundred and eighty divided
by divided by seven notice all we did by
moving the decimal one place to the
right is we multiplied both of these
numbers by 10 which is not going to
change the actual value of the decimal
one other way of thinking about this if
you wanted to write this as a fraction
this is the same thing this is the same
thing as 518 over zero point seven over
zero point seven you multiply both the
numerator and the denominator
by 10:00 you will get 5,180
you will get 5,180 / 7 / 7 so let's
clean this up a little bit just so we
remember what we did so we move the
decimal over to the right one so now
this is just a 7 the decimal is there in
fact we really don't have to write the
decimal anymore just a 7 point you can
imagine seven point two zero so we can
just write this as a seven and then the
518 the decimal is now out here so this
is 580 and let's increase increase this
sign right over here now this is just a
straight up long division problem how
many times does 7 go into 5 well it goes
0 times 0 times 7 actually let's just
let's just cut to the chase 7 doesn't go
into 5 it does go into 51 7 times 7 is
49 so it goes 7 times 7 times 7 is 49
subtract 51 - 49 is 2 and now we can
bring down we can bring down this 8 7
goes into 28 4 times 4 times 7 is 28
subtract you get a 0 now we can bring
down another 0 we want to at least get
to the decimal place so bring down
another 0 right over here when I say get
to the decimal place we can put the
decimal place up here - just to make
sure we're keeping track of the right
place values or that we have the decimal
in the right place so notice I'm very
particular when I'm doing 7 goes into 51
I put the 7 right above the 1 in the 50
ones place when I'm saying 7 it goes
into 28 I'm putting the 4 right above
the 8 in this ones place when we're
doing the division so now we say how
many times does 7 go into 0 well it goes
0 times 0 times 7 is 0 subtract you have
no remainder so we could keep going and
we'll just keep getting zeroes like this
but we see that this is equal to 740 740